pour terminer le festival de danse de
marseille qui fête son dixième
anniversaire l'un des temps forts à lui
ce soir
le ballet national de la ville et son
nouveau directeur présente sa toute
nouvelle création baptisée la cité
radieuse dominique poncet d'un thé
liberty titres contenus des corps aussi
constitué de mobiles pas de doute
possible ce ballet qui s'intitule la
cité radieuse est un hommage à
l'immeuble du même nom
construits par le corbusier en 1952 et
que les marseillais appelle la maison du
fada
bizarrement c'est un belge qui a imaginé
cet hommage un belge débarqué il ya
seulement sept mois à marseille pour
prendre la direction du ballet national
et qui fasciné depuis toujours par l'
architecture est tombé immédiatement
amoureux de la cité
inventé par le corbusier ce qui m'a
surtout inspiré ce lyrisme incroyable
qui lie à ici à travers cette
architecture de béton comme qu'on peut à
partir du béton créer une émotion très
forte aussi une intégration dans la
nature au fil de la chorégraphie
frédéric flamand va dépasser son propos
initial et s'interroger sur les rapports
de l'homme dans la cité
c'est très évocateur de marseille ou si
sa cote est un peu de déconstruction et
en même temps de construction ont
déconstruit les choses après finalement
ça s'enchaîne fait au fur et à mesure
marseille ville ouverte sur le monde
aussi ville de tous les échanges et de
tous les métissages symbolisée ici par
des danseurs venus du monde entier issus
d'univers chorégraphique très différents
connaissant évidemment c'est un échange
entre les danseurs permanents
donc chacun ses chances si technique
donc au fur et à mesure on essaie de
créer une identité commune qui fait que
la même certaines mimiques et les images
les apparences qui ont analysé nos
désirs et nos angoisses pendant des
siècles
peut-être sont en train de prendre le
pouvoir aujourd'hui
l'incidence de la prolifération de
l'image sur la vie quotidienne des
citadins c'est aussi de cela que
traitent cette fascinante chorégraphie
rehausser encore par une scénographie
signée du père de la très grande
bibliothèque de france
l'architecte dominique perrault